if you're old enough you might remember
that mcdonald's used to run a lottery
thing called the monopoly prize game
basically mcdonald's partnered with
hasbro to give away houses cars luxury
cruises or the grand prize of one
million dollars to one out of every 150
million people who ate at
the mcdonald's monopoly has come to life
at mcdonald's
dlt coca-cola or one million dollars
mcdonald's will give you a million
dollars what you do with it is up to you
the excitement of the monopoly game is
back at mcdonald's just by america's
favorite prize these monopoly game
pieces and instant win cards were
attached to drink cups french fry
packets burger boxes and even on
advertising inserts and magazines all
you had to do was find the right set of
properties or an instant win piece and
you could walk away with anything from a
free soda to an entire house and more it
was a genius marketing tactic all over
the us and canada people were going
crazy until it all went wrong armed
robbers would even hold up restaurants
and force employees and customers to
hand over their monopoly game pieces
americans and canadians everywhere were
scrambling to become overnight
millionaires but what was weird was that
it seemed like no one ever won sure
there were odd winners here and there we
bought our breakfast now i got you know
my hash browns coffee whatever
filled it off and
there it was but for a game that was
supposed to have two people win a
million dollars a year things were a
little quiet a little too quiet prices
were disappearing and no one knew why
mcdonald's was giving away 2 million a
year but no one knew who was winning
that money were people hiding their
identities so their friends and family
wouldn't know
was the game rigged not according to
mcdonald's they said they didn't choose
who won an independent security company
was in charge of sending the winning
pieces to locations around the us
12 years and 24 million dollars later
and no one knew who the money went to
and it all centered around a guy named
jerome paul jacobson see jerome paul
jacobson found a way to scan mcdonald's
out of 24 million over 12 years it's a
story of theft greed it involved the
mafia the fbi and he almost got away
with it
[Music]
jerome paul jacobson had a lifelong
streak of bad luck as a teen he applied
for the marines but got turned down due
to high arches in his feet then in 1976
he joined the florida police force but
he injured his arm a year later and was
put on medical leave just as he was
recovering from his injury jerome
collapsed with paralysis in his arms
legs eyes and respiratory system he was
diagnosed with a rare neurological
illness and his wife had to leave her
job to look after him soon after he was
declared unfit to return to work then in
1981 jerome's wife got him a job as a
security auditor where she was working
too it looked like he finally caught a
break but the couple argued so much at
work that two years later they got
divorced a pretty sad life but then
after his divorce things suddenly began
to change at that job jerome got the
reputation of being dedicated having
irreproachable work ethic and coming
down hard on anyone who broke the worlds
he was the perfect security auditor and
worked himself off to where he was in
charge of the firm's most important
clients simon marketing simon marketing
just so happened to manage 500 million
dollars worth of marketing for none
other than mcdonald's when the
mcdonald's monopoly game started in 1987
simon marketing was put in charge of
manufacturing and distributing the game
pieces and jerome made sure they
fulfilled this job without a hitch he
even inspected the shoes of the workers
to make sure they weren't trying to
steal any pieces workers wouldn't be
allowed to go to the bathroom alone and
jerome ordered everyone in the factory
to be under watched 24 hours a day a
year later simon marketing got jerome to
quit his current job to work for them he
was just that good jerome was now put in
charge of taking care of the biggest
winning game pieces he would take
possession of them seal them in
envelopes with tamper-proof tape fly out
to mcdonald's factories in first class
and placed them on food packaging that
would be sent out to mcdonald's
locations he even had the idea to add
watermarks to the tickets so they
couldn't be fixed
so much trust was put into one man and
for years he never thought once about
abusing his power that is until he found
out the system was rigged anyways
now if you care about your life you
really should never eat fast food a good
rule of thumb to feeling a lot better in
every way is to only eat real food and
to make real food you're gonna need some
solid kitchen knives
that's where kamikoto comes in kamikoto
makes these beautiful handcrafted
japanese steel kitchen nut using
century's old traditional techniques
from japan these knives are used by a
ton of chefs at michelin star
restaurants from all across the world
they use real japanese steel source from
mills in japan each knife is
individually inspected and comes with a
lifetime guarantee you get real japanese
steel at a fraction of the cost each
knife comes in a beautiful heavy duty
ash wood box which makes them a great
gift inside you get a certificate of
authenticity the knives feel super solid
like a giant hunk of japanese steel in
your hand and of course they are very
very sharp
i recommend this three-piece konpeki set
which comes with a vegetable knife a
slicing knife and a little utility knife
and right now kamikoto is having their
valentine's day sale which means you get
an extra fifty dollars off when you use
discount code jake tran all you have to
do is head to kamikoto.com jake tran
with the link below choose the knife set
you want use discount code jaytran at
checkout for fifty dollars off that's
kamikoto.com jake tran with discount
code jake tran with the link below
thanks to kamikoto for sponsoring this
video
[Music]
by the late 1980s jerome jacobson was
earning 70 000 a year to fly first class
and boss people around this was all he
ever dreamed of but somehow he still
felt like he wanted more one day jerome
noticed that whenever canada was chosen
as the destination for an instant win
tickets it would immediately be scrapped
and rerouted somewhere in the us simon
marketing was rigging the game this is
an extremely important turning point for
our guy jerome think about it he spent
his entire life struggling only to find
out his entire existence was based on a
lie on a rigged system one can only
imagine how disillusioned he felt
so he collected the information on the
rigging and kept it in his back pocket
for later not long after a set of
anti-tamper stickers were accidentally
mailed to his house these were seals for
the game piece envelopes and it was the
only thing he needed to rig the game in
his favor and he got right to work
whenever he was on a flight to drop off
the game pieces an independent auditor
usually a woman would tag along and
watch him the only place she couldn't
follow him was the toilets so that's
where he made the swap he would open the
envelope remove the instant win card
replace it with a less valuable piece
and then replace the tamper-proof tape
and no one was the wiser now there was
just one last problem to solve in
jerome's rackets he couldn't cash in the
game pieces himself mcdonald's would
want pictures an interview and then they
would realize that he was the main guy
in charge of the game and he would be
exposed so he turned to his friends and
family jerome gave his brother a winning
piece worth 25 thousand dollars then he
gave his local butcher one that was
worth ten thousand dollars in exchange
for two thousand dollars of the earnings
he built up his courage and finally
stole a one million dollar prize piece
and immediately hid it in a safety
deposit box he wanted it all to himself
the next 1 million piece he stole he
sent to the saint jude's trojan research
hospital in tennessee and now that he
built up some confidence it was time to
step it up a notch
[Music]
jerome recruited his clients at random
in his states a guy he met on the plane
someone from his barbershop it was
always random which made it difficult
for cops to connect the dots he would
sell game pieces to people up front or
take a percentage of their winnings
after they claimed the prize then he
would arrange for his clients to travel
out of state rent an apartment a car pay
bills all to make it look like they
really lived in the state they claimed
the prize from jerome was making big
money but then he met a member of the
colombo mafia family a wise guy by the
name of jerry colombo then the operation
just got bigger instead of selling only
the 1 million price pieces jerome
started stealing other prizes too he
still colombo the winning ticket for a
dodge viper and with his new crime
family connections he wasn't just
selling to his neighbors or family
anymore he was selling to mob members
pam's drug dealers anyone with the money
to afford these grand prizes
every time these people claim their
prizes they avoided any publicity they
obviously wanted their privacy but after
12 years of every winner refusing to
show their face people started to get
suspicious by 1998's almost all of
jerome's family members had cashed in on
some kind of game piece and jerome
finally got to enjoy the good life as a
true racketeer he was spending his hard
earned cash on every luxury product he
could get his hands on he bought land
all over the u.s started an antique
collection and paid for his friends and
family to go on expensive cruises
jerome's neighbor watched in amazement
as the number of cars he had just kept
going up often joking about where the
winning tickets were going to but no one
ever expected he was doing anything
wrong he just didn't seem like the type
and jerome kept raking in the money
until something completely unforeseen
happened that would change the course of
jerome's life forever
[Music]
in 1998 around 10 years since this
racket started jerry colombo and his
wife argued almost every day they were
on the brink of divorce and wanted to
give their marriage another shots but it
was never meant to be because soon after
they got into a massive car accident
with his wife behind the wheel jerry
colombo died in the hospital and
suddenly all eyes were on his wife
has she killed them because of their
fighting or had it been our guy jerome
tired of sharing his money without jerry
colombo to find new clients jerome had
to find new middlemen fast and that's
where things went downhill he recruited
three men to help they would find
clients get them to pay and then their
clients would find winning game pieces
in magazines thrown in the back of their
cars or even in a pile of trash at home
no one suspected any foul play and it
was the perfect operation except the
columbo family suspicious angry and
looking for revenge have found a reason
to make jerome their next targets and
soon the whole operation would come
crashing down around him
[Music]
in march 2000 an anonymous caller told
fbi special agent dense that a man named
uncle jerry was rigging the mcdonald's
monopoly game the rats probably someone
from the columbia crime family agent
that immediately called a mcdonald's
spokesperson to share the news and begin
the investigation suddenly a lot of
questions came bubbling to the surface
why did none of the winners want to go
public where are they now and if this
uncle jerry was rigging the game who
else was involved worried mcdonald
suspended the competition in 2001. we
really trusted them to run the game for
us
we had to end the relationship to gain
the trust back with our customers
they quickly identified uncle jury as
our guy jerome but the fbi needed proof
so they launched operation final answer
[Music]
operation final answer involved months
of surveillance on jerome and his
associates the group had become so
comfortable with their methods that
after 12 years they never expected the
fbi to be watching they installed a
wiretap on jerome's phone which led them
to a huge ring of sidekick strip club
owners and convicts fbi surveillance
even trailed jerome all the way to south
carolina where he met with a guy named
john davis the fbi couldn't catch the
transfer of the winning piece on tape
but eight days later the mcdonald's rep
called agent dents and told him that
someone had called in to claim that they
found the winning piece the winner john
davis the man jerome just sold to now
the fbi had everything they needed more
than 50 people were arrested and tried
jerome jacobson was interrogated for six
hours during which he confessed to all
the charges against them he admitted to
having stolen most of the big winning
pieces over the past 12 years and in
exchange for his confession jerome would
accept 15 years in jail all his luxury
cars and property were seized and simon
marketing the company that was in charge
of the monopoly game it was dissolved it
was one of the biggest most complex
forms of mail fraud in history and yet
it was forgotten in less than a day why
because the court case started on
september 10 2001 the very next day the
worst terrorist attack on american soil
happened and america instantly forgot
about the god that rob mcdonald's out of
24 million dollars
[Music]
subscribe for more business
documentaries on money power war and
crime just like this one for free and if
you want a documentary on everyone's
favorite private island owner efree
jepstein we have a private documentary
coming out on him in the next few weeks
available to only members of the channel
click the join button below to be the
first to watch that one and all the
other private documentaries that are
already out and if you join and don't
think it's worth it email me and i will
personally refund you the money
[Music]
you